[Music]
41 seconds of logos movie reminds you of
the fun you had playing Super Mario
Brothers then quickly reminds you that
this time someone else is in the
driver's seat responsible for your fun
and you're alone for the horrible ride
long long time ago the earth was ruled
by dinosaurs this video game adaptation
requires a history dating back to the
dinosaurs also narration also this video
ponine created by what looks to be an
Amiga or some such computer you stubbed
your toe on in an attic somewhere it's
better than this whole movie in case you
confused it for Brooklyn 51 million
years ago also luckily so few people
actually went to see this movie they
aren't talked out of watching Jurassic
Park two weeks later a giant meteorite
struck the earth or horrible CGI or not
quite sure what killed the dinosaurs yet
what if the impact did that meteorite
created a parallel dimension Super Mario
Brothers asks the thought-provoking
question what if the meteorite we
thought killed the dinosaurs is actually
the basis for the stupidest movie
scenario possible using the Mohs scale
I'm going to take a guess and say that
this power crystal could be scratched by
talc it takes an insane amount of time
for this nun to realize there's a huge
freaking basket on the doorstep also
none looks down and sees not a baby I
mean this has to basically be a boombox
in a blanket to her right and yet ah
what the hell let's take in this lost
and lonely piece of electrical equipment
and running just fine on the sidewalks a
minute ago this mystery chick is running
through a busy intersection to test the
limits of death and my willingness to
watch the movie nuns decide yeah let's
open this boombox was he waiting for her
in this exact spot of the tunnel also I
have an idea I bet I can push this
wooden beam it'll cause a major Rock
collapse and I can escape nuns don't
immediately renounce their religion when
they see a human baby hatch from an egg
it required two directors to make this
movie just in case you confused it with
Brooklyn well now who in any profession
end of any storied lineage keeps a
trophy rack of toilet plungers on the
wall I don't care if you're the world's
greatest plumber that's fucking gross
why not wrenches oh you spend money on
this stuff Mario asked Luigi a question
that could very well be a question to
the audience Oh Mario you just gotta
believe
I do believe Mario waits until they're
out of the apartment in the car and
driving down the street to continue this
conversation
Luigi will now tell Mario that he is a
feeling that this is a faster way to go
and he ends up being right but my
question is if you were supposed to turn
left in what scenario do you get to your
destination faster by turning right
faster when I tell you huh no crazy
right turn Luigi took was a never-ending
spiral of adventure to go to Valley they
beat us to it again what did the
riverfront cafe call to plumbers on this
job did they set up a competition for
who could get there the fastest and this
happens often
listen charge you this hole
I'm the boss here um you were definitely
a no possible distance to hear that
question how long you be digging up
these balls as long as our quarterly
last mr. scapelli did she just read that
off a cue card this hotly contested
archaeological construction site is big
enough to draw the local NYC news but
not big enough for anyone of consequence
to hear this monster openly threatened
this archaeologist if there's anyone
digging till I get that guy is gone from
being annoyed about Daisy to taking
mental pictures of her naked and is it
just me or is this seem like the longest
creeper take ever recorded in a history
of movies main characters vehicle breaks
down and smokes to show how horrible
their lives are cliche the movie will go
on to suggest these henchmen have failed
to bring back the princess four times
already my question is why were the most
worthless henchmen in existence even
sent on this mission once let alone five
times more on at the guys carrying a
window to block the villain cliche is
doubly moronic when you see how much
time he has to avoid it okay so this is
1993 in the cellphone craze hadn't hit
yet but is this really the first
freaking pay phone and she could find
also Samantha Mathis isn't my 90s
girlfriend in this scene please step in
Daisy doesn't understand that please
step in the van are usually the last
words you hear before you step in a van
also didn't he just fix the van by
pouring water into the hood in it sure
does Mario I think she can hear him
telling the we do what to say oh okay
okay yeah
here at the police and construction
barricade go home later get dolled up
and then hook it back here cool what
happened to those wacky bad guys that
were chasing her I realized she got a
lift in the plumbing van but even if
they didn't see that did they give up
completely a meteorite hit here a long
time ago
well we think it could be what destroyed
all the dinosaurs or just created the
Ninja Turtles or meteor man bother with
Dinosaurs in Brooklyn well actually they
used to be dodges here two jokes like
this or why we usually don't do bad
comedies in this case what exactly is
the joke maybe if the dinosaurs
relocated to LA you'd have a joke there
bring a nice bathing suit doll it's
something a little strapless so you
don't get a tan line and you probably
want a rock tan Salon lady assumes that
Daisy will want to wear the crystal
entertaining session just so we can get
into some exposition about the crystal
around her neck it's the only thing I
have from when I was found I was
abandoned casual exposition is in casual
you don't know who your mother and your
father I neither bonding by shared
abandonment also did Mario know their
parents are they saying that they aren't
real brothers that the parents died did
they go on for cigarettes and never
returned this is never explained what do
you tonight well hopefully sex but is if
Mario is willing to help Luigi you get
the condom on and undo anything related
tonight I would like to walk you home
but I live in Newark okay okay disguises
far away movie waste everyone's time by
making the henchmen dumber than any
hutchman whoever hinged if you just want
to end this right now I would understand
characters give an open invitation to
the audience also why would you have any
reason to think he isn't super into you
and what you're walking home from a
double-date dinner you have no ties no
one's made any promises here Jesus
Christ man what's the point of walking
your date to the door if you don't watch
her actually go inside until she closes
the door up get still on man she's a
paleontologist her archaeologist and
he's a plumber they're not teenagers
this flirtation by way of a footrace is
one of the stupider things in this movie
and that's saying something important
archaeological dig left completely
unlocked and is wasting tons of
electricity by leaving all the lights on
every night we don't even have any
security here that's what I was calling
about on the phone tonight
I can't get the university to give me
any extra money sure but a padlock maybe
asshole henchmen working force capella
he actually decided to wear scapelli
clothing during the sabotage bellies
flooding the site in fact in the amount
of time it took us to run here it's
probably totally flooded but I'm going
to assume that the flooding stops when
you don't look at it so we still have
time this didn't occur to me to tell you
until we got here
you mean where all the water is spring
that's crazy talk you've got it wrong
five seriously these guys are so stupid
to believe every girl they see is Daisy
and how are they even close how did they
even know to come down here knocked out
with one blow from a flashlight so how
did you get up in time to hear Daisy
screaming down the tunnel that's the
echo how do you know well it's a good
thing Daisy didn't fall in love with a
stockbroker then why even bother with a
CGI when it's gonna look like this no
good thing during whatever this is she
had enough power to jump out just long
enough for Luigi to snag this power
crystal well is it it's another
dimension but apparently allows brief
but unsuccessful escapes John Leguizamo
shatters into a million pieces going
into another dimension
but unfortunately lives to make the pest
now that we see Mario falling through
this dimension I really got to ask now
how the Daisy managed to make it back in
order to give Luigi the crystal and show
them where this portal was remember
she's also being forced by the bad guys
to go through this thing so when her
miraculous semi escape is even more
miraculous seriously the people who did
the special effects on this movie gave
up and said well maybe they're so bad
they're funny I don't know but I'll be
damned if they own kidnapped me and make
me go back to high school
Tunnel in this alternate dimension has
oddly helpful shadows just in case you
happen to be looking for the girl you
fell in love with that night Koopas
underworld steals alternate future bits
timeline from Back to the Future to
Jesus these guys take Daisy everywhere
she can be found at a quick glance movie
that we can only assume is for
three-year-olds manages to sneak in a
porno title joke you know for the adults
in the audience who didn't sneak off to
go see cliffhanger we're going hey
[Music]
mr. e asshole 65 million years we've
been exiled here after the meteorite why
you know for the audience members who
missed the beginning of the movie
because they accidentally walked into
made in America and the princess plan
which after so many years you surely
heard so many times you're tired of it
but again for the people who decided to
poke their head into this movie who were
accidentally watching slipper a second
time and I'll finally people to merge
our world with theirs why do you need to
merge the dimensions can't you all just
go through that walk near the dig site
and kill all the humans or whatever you
want to do and I'm going through the
dimensional merge discount Mars
underground city from Total Recall how
is it that these dinosaur people evolved
into regular ass people there appears to
be no difference at all to humans down
here and it makes the whole thing with
the dumb henchmen not being able to
distinguish one woman from another even
more curious mannequins dumped luminous
mannequin how did anyone think this was
the way to do a Mario movie yeah you
can't have a guy running on platforms
and hopping on mushrooms and call it a
movie no I guess that's the plot of Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas but still I
think you start there and brainstorm the
first thing I would do is tackle how
Mario knows where to hit those secret
powerup blocks it would be epic I tell
you wait a shoehorn a beloved Mario
character into your movie guys and you
did have to tell us who this was because
he in no way looks like these women
either seem to be okay with being
kidnapped or the actresses realize what
a stupid movie this is why do they need
for guys to take pictures it's because
of this extremely long and pointless
they think it's a firing range joke is
it how are these two plumbers so easily
determined to be the two plumbers Koopa
asked for do they not have plumbers in
this universe and that's why they stood
out because if so how does anyone here
even know what a plumber is or looks
like okay so Mario extends his hand to
Koopa who doesn't shake it because he's
a big germaphobe but then Koopa himself
extends his hand to Mario like it never
happened
how is Koopa able to pretend to be a
lawyer I mean they are from Earth sure
but his picture is all over the place
and why even bother what does he gain by
pretending to be a lawyer it's also hard
to believe they got Bob Hoskins and
Dennis Hopper into this movie Leguizamo
I understand he was just starting out
but Hoskins and Hopper must have really
needed to pay for a summer home or
something what
the organism did you evolve from
Tyrannosaurus Rex
the lizard king thank you very much
t-rex was single-cell goddamn I think
this movie just broke science Jordi
evolution will be a living nightmare if
you don't tell me where that meteorite
pieces Koopa assumes the Mario Brothers
know what the rock is can he not simply
say the meteorite piece Daisy was
wearing around her neck like he did to
his dumbass goons earlier we thought and
two feet taller for some reason now
maybe the D evolution machine can change
a creatures height but how did the
uniform also grow to accommodate toads
new body they're able to do this without
much resistance at all and staged
fighting looks like first-year dental
students start at an amateur improv
group during study break also that punch
from Luigi let's run that back again can
we easily my favorite thing about this
movie luigi knows everything about the
devolving machine doing what what can he
do he turned on a computer and started
typing does it help start the car hell
if we know to confer ever to figure out
how to start this car but he
automatically knows which one of the
four levers goes up and which one goes
down in order to put the car and drive
the pursuing cops both shoot at the
Mario Brothers car between them and
nothing of consequence happens then
Mario slams on the brakes and the two
cops shooting easily explode each other
in seconds marks the wheel to the right
but the car goes to the left is the
steering inverted on these vehicles or
is he doing that maneuver from cars go
right to go left
bungee fungus ex machina plainly the
prints this guy hasn't even met the
princess yet despite her incredible
importance to the plot does this machine
only deal in extremes I advanced and no
average or slightly smarter than a
baguette you could use that on these had
been earlier too
do you know what the square root of 20
6401 is what are you talking about 191
it is not you do not return with the
plumbers and the rock I shall personally
killing isn't the rock all that matters
are you hell-bent on a revenge kick now
Yoshi looks dumb all bad guys are ripest
hey that's it you've just came in here
and gave no information at all did a
couple of creepy things and now it's
time for her to go but why all so nice
of the Goomba troops to put toads
harmonica back on his neck after his D
evolution so we'd always be able to tell
which boom bow was him Koopa is a dick
do she what am I doing with my life that
I just said that sentence so did the
evolution machine simply improve their
vocabulary what goddamn ripoff also
seriously aside from all the names is
anything about this movie like the video
game series that inspired it where's
Daisy but 4s footprint also does it
matter where Daisy is she's in that city
of just escaped with all the cops
looking for you do you simply want to go
back do you have a plan Iraq is a piece
of a special meteorite which was chipped
off upon impact 65 million years ago it
was amazingly the only piece of the
meteorite that chipped off yes you see
once this rock is reinserted into the
meteorite our two dimensions will
reunite and we will become one actually
some crazy bullshit some guy wrote as a
sex poem which he crumpled and threw in
the wastebasket but then his roommate
came along unraveled it and made it the
basis for this movie when they just come
through before like you clowns why are
you full he's been sealed off for years
until someone on your side blasted it
open again yes but it is open now right
so who cares if he didn't do it before
why isn't he doing it now character says
this just to taunt the audience but why
does a completely separate universe and
world that evolved from dinosaurs have a
Statue of Liberty it's hard enough to
buy that they evolved into something
humanoid but a statue of liberty the
what are you waiting for was the plunger
even necessary to this plan look for the
red spike big Bertha's the bouncer
though right
wouldn't you have run into her on your
way in here discount throw advance
is she not going to remember stealing
there off from you like yesterday
bouncer at the club is allowed to dance
on the main floor like a customer I
think she might be a terrible dancer
guys music suddenly changes to slow song
shortly after main character's decision
to fast dance with someone they would
normally not slow dance with cliche
Mario tries to reacquire the rock with
undetected sexual assault big birth that
continues to not detect Mario's attempts
to remove her necklace I mean does your
skin not feel also Mario was in a bright
yellow suit you really can't find him
everybody walked the dinosaurs and
especially on the nose soundtrack choice
I think and that's not a compliment
that's the plan does that even mean why
is the dance floor made of grated metal
is it just for this stupid moment of
necklace tension why is she helping him
because he fake seduced her and stole
the rock back she stole from him
thankfully at the 1 hour 2 minute mark
movie finally finds an excuse for Mario
and Luigi to jump hot do you know this
garbage truck is going to Cooper's Tower
why would a truck full of garbage go
anywhere but a dumping facility that's
so woods for you and I've got two words
for you I hate you you fucking dick and
here's the sledge Goldberg just throwing
trash in a pile out in public for no
reason other than allowing Mario and
Luigi to get farther in the quest Jews
like to friend to keep abaya
except he already told you a long time
ago that he lost his tools so this
particular plumbers lesson is just you
being a dickhead REO finds perfect
disguises that both he and the weed you
can wear in the first Locker he opens so
here's the origin story of Mario and
Luigi but that leaves out pork Donkey
Kong biggest elevators ever Luigi is
plotting an escape by making the goombas
dance which I admit is highly original
but it also shows how unsatisfying it is
when your villains have the brainpower
of lice goddamn she's been petting this
thing for forever
why all the subterfuge if you were
planning on killing her anyway you've
got a stabber already seen of Goomba
soldiers all dancing in the elevator
isn't stupid enough so filmmakers
decided to have them spontaneously pair
off for a couple stands for virtually no
reason at all the goombas allow again
spike to simply go free fire
extinguisher is handy just in case one
of your friends is on fire besides does
Koopa Stowers seem like the kind of
place where they follow fire codes or
care about safety also what happened to
the other goombahs they said toad on
fire and then pieced out and they show
up out of nowhere after every possible
good scenario for the protagonists could
happen like they were frozen in time or
something you guys have no clue where
you need to go in this Tower
so risking your life for this jump is
stupid issue also are you just assuming
those dancing goombas are still in the
elevator where you left them why didn't
you stay on top of the elevator and wait
until they left why not go back there
are so many other choices luigi jumps
gets miraculously saved by a random hook
doesn't detect it tells Mario about it
and have him jump too but instead of
dying Mario hits a fungus trampoline and
lips do I have that about right Jesus
Christ this movie is aggressively stupid
can you hear me intercom speaker just
happens to be in a place that is total
bullshit is this asshole been doing this
communicate so let me pull it out of the
living organism and see if it can still
help hopeless all along pound it
nintendo ever let this piece of Mario
movie get made huh yeah sure just run
anywhere guys it's not like you need to
be careful or anything
also Luigi and Daisy decide to run out
of their hiding spot just as Koopa in
his guards are walking by kind of prison
cell is this god damn it Texans release
me now but why why would a flamethrower
burst a door open like a battering ram
potential princess holding cell turns
out to have a racing tube to freedom
built in righteous hour that gue bestows
flaming from the friction between his
feet and the icy snow-covered to
seriously denied miss the take shrooms
now instructions earlier in this film
also how did these assholes catch up
they were way behind whatever the fuck
this is that makes this possible also
goombas could easily go around it just
like they saw Mario do but decide yeah
whatever mattress also does this air
duct lead out into the town is there a
reason for that
mattress just happens to fly to the bad
guys who for reasons entirely unknown
are walking outside into the city right
now looks like I will
and you just use your default organ
already and in this yeah sure just set
that rocket boot to attack mode it'll do
the rest come up and so don't care about
Luigi Mario but you got a problem with
that problem what god damn piece of
fever dream of a movie am i watching
sorry I just shot my television can
someone tell me how this thing ends now
Farren mine only in retrospect is
letting Lena go earlier seem dumb at all
hindsight is twenty-twenty my friend
caught you up on the plot of this movie
yet good let's go stop evil been seeing
the meteorite like this I wonder how it
just the smallest fragment of it got
dislodged from its body and how anyone
knew that it was missing that it would
merge dimensions if anyone put it back
bombs that require winding also even if
this thing goes nuclear when it explodes
it's walking slowly enough to be my vote
for mostly useless autonomous bond in
movie history
whoever believes you is probably
homeless but we'll worry about that
later a show makes an impression hahaha
puns will merge you why isn't everything
else around them disintegrating right
now and why aren't Daisy and Luigi being
turned into soda bubbles right now oh
that is some weirdly prescient creepy
bolt there also you mean you actually
got this far with an actual policeman
with that crazy ass story
luckily Koopas tower emerges into the
real world just in time to be hard proof
the location of Koopa and Mario's merge
makes no sense whatsoever why are they
not in the tower still why has no one
else from that world appearing out of
nowhere and what the hell happened to
Iggy and Spike in this movie seeing as
how the merge simply allowed Koopa to
show up on earth I still can't figure
out why the portal everyone else was
using didn't suffice gun turns humans
into Apes instead of making them with it
even if it is Capelli everyone is
laughing and it's not horrified that a
human being just got turned into a
monkey how did he know whispering to the
mushroom would cause it to grow and
protect him
I guess I'll just have to use that
portal now everyone in the city was
still here for some reason I guess this
merging thing knows which characters to
send to a new place and which ones not
this thing still hasn't exploded yet
it's a good thing they let toad have a
harmonica when they tranked him and just
happens to still be a good guy and Luigi
taught the goombas how to dance or else
this plot development might have seemed
silly this lady was here waiting to
throw her boots - Luigi just in case he
showed up at a random time and just
happened to need them this asshole bomb
also has Reeboks on why didn't they just
make this a cartoon for God's sake let's
steal that evolution machine upstairs
and make a fortune while making the
world a better place shall we or are we
gonna forget about that amazing
scientific breakthrough during this
happy ending alternate universe citizens
wait all of one minute before
whitewashing Koopas reign nobody did
anything to turn this fungus back into a
human and holy they drank Lance
Henriksen into this didn't they they
drank everyone into this didn't they
it's solid but why oh yes this long
separated piece of meteorite actually
acts as an activator and controller for
the mystical portal between our two
worlds I totally forgot no wait a minute
what the hell dinosaur goodbye waves I
call them the super mario brothers no
you wouldn't
also rule credits what's wrong believe
this obviously awful movie thought it
was going to get a sequel I believe it
[Music]
oh Jesus Christ I must say we have a
very exciting proposal a video game
based on your many adventures movie
shoehorns a stupid-ass end credits scene
with Iggy and Spike that absolutely
nobody saw in the pre Marvel Studios era
hell I doubt even movie theater usher
saw this because they were able to clean
the auditorium so quickly
[Music]
dragons eggs Daenerys from the shadow
lands beyond - I bred Raptors before we
get started does anyone want to get out
[Music]
you can dance I don't lie
you can't what am i doing
teasing my dick you got potential though
I could teach you
that you gonna look at me mommy baby
wants to fuck two sides of an isosceles
triangle is equal to the square root of
the remaining side for starters don't
ever kiss me again